[Musique]
time hospital l'une des plus grandes
cliniques de chirurgie esthétique de
shanghai des dizaines de jeunes femmes
viennent tous les jours se renseigner ou
se faire opérer le docteur jean lang un
chirurgien spécialiste de la mâchoire
explique à une patiente les détails de
l'opération à venir
certains bus c'est la largeur du bas du
visage qui est importante c'est rare
mais il faudra aussi réduire l'angle du
haut de la mâchoire
là vous voyez ce n'est pas régulier il
faut affiner leurs taux regardez
seulement après l'opération l'angle de
l'os de la mâchoire est d'environ 120
degrés ce chirurgien est réputé depuis
20 ans dans le domaine de la chirurgie
réparatrice
il a été embauché à prix d'or par le
times hospital pour se consacrer
uniquement à la chirurgie esthétique
depuis il effectue une centaine
d'opérations par mois sa renommée est
telle que les patients arrivent de tout
le pays
et pourtant en chine modifié son
apparence est un sujet tabou
cette jeune femme a accepté de nous
répondre mais à visage masqué si jamais
je vais vous faire repérer car même si
mon visage ne dérange personne
mon entourage considère que je suis un
peu fatigué enfants ici en chine quand
on se fait opérer c'est ton secret
personne non pâle et moi aussi je ne
vais rien dire
le grand jour est arrivé
stressé la patiente est emmené vers la
salle d'opération
[Musique]
est ce que vous vous fait opérer pour
chercher du travail
[Musique]
par la seule non c'est juste pour avoir
une vie meilleure
[Musique]
sois sûr mais vous savez il ya de plus
de jeunes femmes qui viennent me voir
pour ce faire raffiner le visage et elle
arrive tout avec des motivations
différentes certaines veulent modifier
leur image pour trouver un mari par
exemple ou d'autres pour trouver du
travail
toutes les deux minutes en chine une
femme subit une intervention de
chirurgie esthétique
un million d'opérations par an un record
mondial
en cinq ans le nombre de ses
interventions a été multiplié par dix
avec l'augmentation du niveau de vie et
l'émergence d'une bourgeoisie a tiré par
l'occident le business de la beauté pèse
aujourd'hui 3 milliards d'euros par an
l'opération s'est bien déroulée
c'est une réussite je suis content du
résultat une nouvelle révolution est en
marche dans la chine du 21e siècle
mais quand les yeux se débride et quand
les jambes s'allonge au nom des critères
de beauté occidentaux la société change
de repères
[Musique]
shanghai 20 millions d'habitants la
ville symbole de l'ouverture économique
de la chine
en ces temps de crise trouver un emploi
relève du parcours du combattant
fan fang swan élimé sont étudiante en
dernière année à l'université de
shanghai
en attendant de devenir maîtresse
d'école
elle cherche un travail alimentaire et
plus chaque semaine les petites annonces
je concède deux journaux c'est combien 2
centimes
il a regardé il ya un poste dans un
restaurant tu veux aller travailler dans
la restauration par mois regardez s'il
recherchait 68 diplômés ce n'est pas bon
ben si c'est pourquoi pour des logiciels
qu'est ce que tu as trouvé regardez
cherche personne joli visage belle
silhouette bonne voie et très motivés
ils sont très exigeants pour le physique
il faut mesurer au moins 1 m 64 mignonne
à avoir de gros yeux plusieurs annonces
indique explicitement les critères
physiques indispensables al embauche
actuellement les diplômes universitaires
ne servent plus à rien aujourd'hui à
shanghai tous les étudiants sont
diplômés alors ça ne suffit plus il faut
avoir déjà de l'expérience
professionnelle mais il faut aussi être
beau ceux qui étudient le commerce
international se font opérer pour
trouver un bon travail se font vers les
yeux ou bien grandir le nez car launay
des chinois est trop plat ils ne
subissent pas dans ces serments de
grosses interventions mais très souvent
elles se font refaire le nez et les yeux
quand même
pour les six millions d'étudiants
chinois qui quitteront la fac cette
année la chirurgie esthétique fera la
différence
leur salaire sera en moyenne 30% plus
élevé que celui des autres xiaoping
points comme au siège du plus grand site
internet de chine qui rassemble toutes
les annonces de recherche d'emploi nous
avons rendez vous avec l'un des
responsables il nous parle de cette
discrimination à l'embauché
la loi interdit la discrimination à l
embauche en raison de la race de la
nationalité ou du sexe mais aucun texte
n'empêche les employeurs de mentionner
des critères physiques dans leurs
annonces
si on compare ce qu'il se passe
aujourd'hui ça rapport à il ya cinq six
dix ans sauf que ces critères sont de
plus en plus demandés il est
indispensable d'être beau surtout si
l'on veut travailler dans le secteur du
divertissement des compagnies aériennes
ou de l'import export
les filles qui postulent à des postes de
secrétaires par exemple doit vraiment
être très belle
kindia est une shanghaïenne de 23 ans
nourrit aux séries américaines et à
leurs héroïnes aux grands yeux elle rêve
de beauté à l'occidentale en regardant
les magazines féminins
cette secrétaire s'est déjà fait refaire
le nez
les paupières et la mâchoire des
opérations qu'elle a gardée secrète et
qui lui ont coûté quatre mille euros
toutes ses économies
un investissement considérable pour
cette jeune femme qui gagne 300 euros
par mois
[Musique]
on peut je trouve que cette occidental
est très belle ses yeux sont profonds
son visage est une très belle forme
elles ont vraiment beaucoup plus de
classe que nous les chinoises
je suis très satisfaite après mes
opérations me perçois de moins en moins
comme un asiatique
pour nous ce n'est pas flagrant mais
selon les critères chinois qin ja
ressemble maintenant à une européenne
des lentilles de contact bleus et des
fossiles complète son nouveau look
maintenant mon patron apprécié que je
l'accompagnant rendez vous à l'extérieur
tenue à bourges était plus une employé
ordinaire
j'ai vraiment un meilleur statut dans
l'entreprise aujourd'hui j'ai enfin
trouvé un petit ami qui m'aiment
beaucoup l'amour en prime pour les
chinoises la chirurgie esthétique semble
apporter la solution à de nombreux
problèmes
king a d'ailleurs prévu de refaire ses
seins et ses dents dès qu'elle en aura
les moyens
l'icône nationale
l'ambassadrice de la chirurgie
esthétique c'est à oulu la pionnière en
la matière
en 2003 elle est devenue célèbre après
avoir subi 17 interventions
chirurgicales en sept mois la voici
avant ces opérations paupières nez
menton simple fait ce ventre jambes
la chirurgie là entièrement transformé
[Musique]
m
aloulou a aujourd'hui 30 ans sept ans
après ses premières opérations elle a
pris 20 kilos la peau de son visage est
abîmée à cause des traitements qu'elle
prend pour éclaircir son temps cependant
pour des médias chinois elle reste
incontournable dès que l'on parle de
chirurgie esthétique
ici elle est interviewée par la
télévision nationale qui prépare une
émission sur le thème la beauté au
bistouri et le marché du travail nous
n'accompagnons dans les beaux quartiers
de pékin où elle a rendez vous avec sa
marraine
il fait froid dehors oui il fait très
froid entre c'est cette femme de 50 ans
elle même adepte du bistouri qui lui a
conseillé de se soumettre à toutes ses
opérations à oulu lui voue une affection
sans bornes car elle a toujours été à
ses côtés comme une mère pour vivre la
célébrité seignanx
j'ai modifié mon apparence de la tête
aux pieds j'en ai beaucoup discuté avec
elle et j'ai suivi ses conseils car je
lui fais totalement confiance
trois candidats je suis très fier d'elle
ça ressemble à n'diaye partout où l'on
va je dis que c'est ma fille
à une époque il nous arrivait
d'enregistrer cinq émissions en un après
midi
ces opérations lui ont permis
d'atteindre un certain niveau de vie et
une bonne position sociale
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de filles qui
veulent me ressemble et elle voudrait
être si célèbre que moi quand on peut
faire de la chirurgie esthétique au
chien normalement oui ça devrait être
possible si unis pollution alors la
marraine tient à nous montrer les
souvenirs de gloire dont elles sont
toutes les deux très fier ok c'était une
séance de dédicace de mon livre son
chien j'ai aussi joué dans un film en
2004 ou 2005 je ne me souviens plus puis
plusieurs chaînes de télévision ont
proposé de présenter des émissions
ces moments restent ancrés dans sa
mémoire mais à loulou n'est plus ce
qu'elle était il ya sept ans elle ne
s'avoue pas vaincu et multiplie les
liposuccions en tout elle affirme avoir
dépensé 50 mille euros pour être plus
belle elle passe ses journées dans les
salons de beauté et les magasins
et ces soirées dans des bars à refaire
le monde avec un groupe d'amis
ils sont enfin arrivés si on verse de
l'eau chaude les vêtements vont
disparaître ce sont des services
japonaise ensuite de ses amis à hulu est
un modèle de réussite et un élément de
fierté nationale représente la beauté
des chinoises après l'ouverture
économique de la chaîne nous titiller
les hommes ici espère tous que leurs
femmes suivront son exemple notre vrai
et oui en chine à des dons qu'elles
seront aussi courageuse et moderne
qu'elle fait lyncher warner pour de
nombreux chinois a alloué le symbole
d'une chine qui avance car du temps de
mao
il était interdit de s'intéresser aux
choses frivole la beauté était synonyme
de bourgeoisie de décadence la femme
parfaite été robuste en bleu de travail
et sans maquillage
dans la chine d'aujourd'hui
un sondage récent a montré que 47 % des
chinois auraient recours à la chirurgie
esthétique
s'il en avait les moyens cela signifie
que près de 600 millions de personnes
seraient prêtes à changer de tête
un engouement toujours plus grand
[Musique]
line zinc et sociologues
l analyse ces résultats dans un des plus
grands instituts de sondage du pays
de nombreux facteurs peuvent expliquer
ce boom le développement économique est
aussi l'amélioration des techniques
chirurgicales qui rendent les opérations
moins dangereuses les mentalités ont
beaucoup changé car dans la tradition
chinoise on ne doit pas transformer le
corps que nos parents nous ont donné
cela porte mal c'est pourquoi les jeunes
femmes qui subissent des opérations
comme celle des saints n'en parle pas
ouvertement les vers ont pourtant sauté
surfant sur la vague du succès de loulou
la chine organise en décembre 2004 le
premier concours de beauté réservé aux
adeptes du bistouri mais chirurgie
esthétique fait un tabac pour y
participer les vins aspirantes au titre
national de renzaho mind ou de beauté
artificielle ont dû fournir un
certificat médical prouvant au moins une
opération fengyang la gagnante a
remporté en plus de son trophée
un rôle dans une fiction télévisée et un
chèque de 5000 euros
aujourd'hui fabienne vie en mandchourie
dans le nord-est de la chine
elle a trouvé un travail tout
naturellement dans la clinique qui l'a
opéré l'établissement lui a proposé un
contrat de mannequin pour ses photos
publicitaires mais aussi de relations
publiques avec les clients grâce à elle
cette clinique est devenue la plus en
vue de toute la région
[Musique]
il y à différentes techniques vous
pouvez vous faire opérer ou alors faire
des injections
cela coûte 300 euros je peux voir un
chirurgien manque bien sûr je vais vous
prendrez rendez vous mon rôle est très
important
je conseille les clientes et croyez moi
je suis bien placé pour leur donner mon
avis au moment de partir elle est encore
sollicité par une cliente
l'opération se fait au niveau du cuir
chevelu attendez je vais vous montrer
on fait une incision à ce niveau puis on
tire la peau en arrière qu'est ce qui va
le plus changé autres le feront
on va vous tirer aussi toute la peau du
visage et ça va vous changer parfois
[Musique]
le business de la beauté explose
aujourd'hui 1 millions d'établissements
se partagent ce marché juteux des
hôpitaux publics
reconverti dans la chirurgie esthétique
mais aussi des milliers d' institut de
beauté ordinaire qui se sont improvisés
clinique du jour au lendemain
les autorités ont essayé de réglementer
en 2006 ce développement anarchique et
d'imposer aux médecins une licence
d'exercer mais les contrôles sont rares
même les cliniques qui ont pignon sur
rue non pas forcément les papiers en
règle nous nous rendrons en caméra
cachée dans cet établissement qui a
toutes les apparences d'une clinique
sérieuse bien situés dans shanghai
nous nous faisons passer pour une
patiente potentiel
accompagné de sa traductrice bonjour
elle voudrait se faire opérer les seins
suivez moi s'il vous plaît nous la
suivons et lui demandant des détails
pratiques sur l'opération les prix
varient selon les prothèses entre 1000
et 7000 euros
combien de temps dure l'opération
l'opération dure une demi heure et il
n'y a qu'une nuit d'hospitalisation nous
demandons ensuite avoir la licence
d'exercer du chirurgien hélas la
générosité
ne vous inquiétez pas notre médecin à
bien cette licence mais on ne peut pas
vous la montrer nous ne pouvons vous
présenter qu'une photocopie que nous
allons la voir
malheureusement non car les employés du
bureau sont déjà partis oui ils ont déjà
fini de travailler nous les conservons
très précieusement mais vous pouvez vous
faire opérer de demain et votre taux de
réussite il est 200%
on n'a jamais eu d'échec
nous nous rendons dans un deuxième
institut de chirurgie esthétique pour
essayer de trouver enfin quelqu'un qui
aurait une licence notre prétexte est
toujours le même une opération des seins
cela tombe bien nous avons un très bon
docteur spécialisé dans les prothèses
mammaires
l'infirmière semblent pressés de nous
aider il peut vous opérer dès demain si
vous voulez est-ce qu'il a tous les
diplômes et les licences d'exercer
soyez rassurés c'est obligatoire c'est
élémentaire
nous insistons pour les voir docteur
temps que se prépare pour une
intervention
vous pourrez le rencontrer après et fait
beaucoup de stages et de formations à
l'étranger
on vous fait confiance
mais peut-on voir quand même la licence
d'exercer vous savez ce sont des
documents tellement précieux que je n'y
ai pas accès excusez moi je ne vais pas
pouvoir discuter plus longtemps avec
vous car plusieurs autres clientes
m'attendent
visiblement la réglementation est
laxiste
n'importe qui peut s'improviser
chirurgien esthétique
[Musique]
pire encore certaines opérations
interdites se pratique quand même à
l'abri des regards dans la banlieue de
pékin au bord d'une autoroute
cet hôpital se niche derrière en karaoké
on effectue ici une opération
particulièrement lourde et dangereuse
l'allongement des jambes en principe
cette intervention n'est autorisée que
si la santé du patient est en cause mais
ici on la pratique simplement pour faire
gagner quelques centimètres au client le
docteur babylangues se présente comme un
pont en la matière mais nous sommes
surpris de constater qu'à une demi-heure
de l'intervention il rencontre sa
patiente pour la première fois sofiane à
vous faire allonger les jambes va vous
aider considérablement mais il faut bien
réfléchir à certains droits avant tout
vous devez savoir que c'est une
opération qui va vous immobiliser
pendant un an
vous ne pourrez pas aller au travail ni
à l'université
il peut survenir quelques petits
problèmes mais si l'opération est bien
fait il n'y en aura pas
j'ai déjà procédé à trois mille
opérations il n'y a jamais eu de rater
réfléchissez bien avant de vous faire
opérer ça peut être dangereux et ça fait
mal il faut le savoir
allongez vous mettez vos jambes sur le
lien la patiente cache son visage
terrorisé à l'idée qu'on puisse la
reconnaître je vais opérer à cet endroit
en faisant une incision d'un demi
centimètre et le système de fixation va
être installée ici sur chaque jambe
[Musique]
avant les principaux risques était que
les eaux ne se résoud pas bien ou que
les gens ne soit paralysée par des
problèmes de circulation du sang ou
d'autres problèmes médicaux
l'opération est très lourde
nous demandons à cette jeune femme
pourquoi elle accepte de courir de tels
risques
pourquoi souhaitez-vous faire opérer
tous l'aider mais venu d'un coup justice
pour être plus grande
nous n'en saurons pas plus cette jeune
femme de 22 ans va subir deux heures
d'opération
[Musique]
des broches métalliques vont être vissé
sur ses jambes avant d'en casser les
zones il faudra ensuite six mois de
rééducation et un an avant qu'elle ne
puisse remarcher normalement si tout va
bien à la clé elle aura gagné 8 à 10 cm
elle n'est pas la seule malgré les
risques les chinois qui mesurent en
moyenne 1 m 65 continuent à avoir
recours à cette opération
si la chirurgie esthétique est en plein
essor
le nombre de victimes d'opérations raté
lui aussi ne cessent d'augmenter pour
assister ces personnes en détresse
un numéro d'appel gratuit a été mis en
place depuis un an par la ville de
shanghai que puis je faire pour vous
vous voulez vous faire agrandir le nez
vous voulez changer la pointe du nez
avez vous déjà eu une intervention si
vous avez un moment de libre venez
rencontrer un de nos spécialistes
il va examiner votre cas ce numéro
gratuit a déjà reçu dix mille appels
le service est dirigée par le docteur
tiendrait non il y à tout type de
personne qui a peur au début on recevait
surtout des coups de fil concernant des
opérations ratées
l'explication postopératoire ces
personnes ont besoin des coudes on
analyse leur profil psychologique et on
les dirige vers des spécialistes qui
vont faire de leur mieux pour les aider
parfois on résout des problèmes on
conseillant de nouvelles opérations plus
adapté se faire réopérer c'est ce que
l'on conseille ici à la moitié des
personnes qui appellent et ce n'est pas
un hasard car le service est hébergé par
une clinique de chirurgie esthétique
nous avons essayé de parler avec des
victimes d' intervention ratée mais
aucune n'a accepté de témoigner
[Musique]
nous avons en revanche rencontré un
jeune homme qui lui a trouvé son bonheur
grâce à la chirurgie esthétique au
centre de la chine dans le veine and à
11 heures de train de pékin zhen wang 25
ans est devenu très populaire depuis le
printemps dernier
séance de dédicaces enregistrement de
show publicitaire animations
commerciales testing pour téléfilm zen
vit désormais à 100 à l'heure sur ces
images filmées par son agent on voit que
dès qu'ils arrivent quelque part il
déchaîne les foules
l'avis de zen a basculé le jour où des
amis nous ont dit qu'ils ressemblaient à
100 signale un des comiques les plus
populaires de la télévision chinoise
munis de la photo de son modèle il s'est
fait opérer le nez le menton et les
sources m à gauche zen à droite la vraie
star les cheveux le look les expressions
zen s'est transformé en une contrefaçon
de south indian il est devenu presque
aussi célèbre que le vrai comédien
il va même jusqu'à porter des lunettes
sans verre pour mieux dire semblait en
devenant une copie de xiao shenyang
j'ai tout de suite été très sollicités
ils me demandent des autographes on m'a
dit de partout et je fais des pubs dont
la rue quand je prends le taxi on se
demande toujours si je suis le succès
c'est super c'est une émotion que je
n'avais jamais ressenti
on n'avait jamais demandé un autographe
dans l'ancien même dans mes rêves les
plus fous je n'aurais jamais imaginé
cela ici
c'est après militons programme va être
chargé qui doit aller tourner une pub
ensuite nous irons signe un contrat pour
une animation commerciale dans une
entreprise du rhénane
il y a six chaînes de télé qui ont
appelé et qui veulent tourner une
émission sur toi les petites et les
moyennes entreprises qui font appel à
moi non pas les budgets suffisante pour
embaucher le vrai si à votre avenir et
une pour représenter leurs produits moi
je coûte beaucoup moins cher
peu importe qu'il soit le vrai ou pas le
but c'est de rendre les gens heureux
c'est mon opinion au revoir je vais à
mon cours de danse à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
bonjour
oh
ni
m
[Musique]
pour le moment je lui enseigne les bases
il y encore plus beaucoup de travail il
n'a aucune connaissance de la musique
quand je les rencontre et elle était
comme une feuille blanche sur laquelle
il fallait tout écrire
[Musique]
zen a totalement endosser les habits de
son modèle
il peaufine ses pas de danse et ne se
lasse pas d'imiter les sketches de la
vraie star plus la chirurgie esthétique
a changé sa vie comme elle est empreinte
de changer le visage de la chine